please welcome our very good friend mr
jack black
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah jack
we uh we have quite a tale uh to tell
our audience attempt
to do it will sound quite strange but is
absolutely
true uh you were the healthiest i've
ever seen you
yesterday yesterday
and now we see you here uh uh
in i think look banged up shape you
don't look well
let me just start off by saying i love
you conan
i love you too and i've uh
i've always loved you since uh since the
year
no one says i love you with more menace
than jack black
i mean i loved you from before that but
that was the first time we met
in person my first ever talk show
appearance and i was scared as hell i
was petrified i'd never been in front of
a late night audience before
and you were so smart and funny and
kind it was the best way to like enter
the late night television world
and i will always feel a special
connection with you and worship you
and um and i have to say andy
is the most incredible sidekick of all
yes he is
when you come at him rip racer smart
[ __ ] off the top of your head no one
else i could never replace you
i know that i said i wanted to reproduce
you i want to set the record straight
right now that means a lot
that was hot air i claimed i was going
to replace you
and that was all [ __ ] i could never
do it i'm not smart enough
wow what happened there i'm getting off
the rails here look
there's a lot of pressure here because
there's not this show there's no
pressure
we love you we've loved you since the
time we met you uh you are an absolute
delight and
love having you on the last show i just
feel a little bad and i need to tell
this story
do you want me do you want to tell it i
don't want to tell it why don't you tell
it
we wanted it to be extra special uh
because you know he's cones and he's uh
he's the king and and so we caught we
cut we came up with this big musical
number that was gonna
involve a lot of like physicality and
and and i was going to get injured in
the middle of the musical
you were going to fake an injury take an
injury and then the paramedics were
going to come in and take me on a gurney
out into the ambulance and then i was
going to say
hell no get me i'd die i love carnage
and i was gonna run back and we filmed
this yesterday we did a pre-tape
of me running back to the theater and
you did it time and time again
you kept doing it and uh you you
there were discussions like it could be
better maybe it could be better you are
a perfectionist
the crazy thing is i actually injured
myself
for real running back right out here
right out here he's doing a bit he we're
pre-taping a bit that we were gonna roll
in tonight
where jack pretends to hurt himself and
then
we thought we had him we were like we'll
do one more he's running around
rolls your ankle i roll you go down
we're all horrified we go rushing out
and then
crumpled we have an ambulance there to
shoot the bit
this is the funniest part i know that
you were in great pain the funniest part
is we had an ambulance there
and so i'm yelling at these two guys
like we got to help we got to help him
and they were like no
we're actors
and then i they said but we just need an
ace bandage and i said we'll get one out
of the ambulance and they said no
it's a fake ambulance so then someone we
have these two
guys dressed as ambulance drivers with
an ambulance who drove to cvs
and bought ace bandages it's the
stupidest
thing i've ever seen it was a really
quick run to cvs though i have to say
they made it wrapped up the ankle
and today i went and uh just to be safe
i got an mri
and they were like yeah nope it's a real
sprain you got you got some damage there
you're gonna have to take it easy no
dancing no
running no physical craziness for a
while you're gonna have to heal up
and i was so bummed because i was like i
wanted to be the best
guest of all time for your final episode
and instead
i am literally the lamest
but can i just say something to me and
i'm sorry you got hurt and i know you're
gonna get better soon
i was sorry i felt so terrible when you
fell but it
also i have to say felt fitting
for for our show you know here we are
and when shows you know
when carson went up in letterman and all
these legends go off the air everything
is meticulous
of course we would think of a bit with
jack
where jack pretends to get hurt and
while shooting it jack gets hurt
that we're the only show that would ever
don't you think we're the only show in
the history of the medium
that would ever do that it's somehow
fitting right johnny johnny would have
had
jack's shot
[Laughter]
just how they did it i thought about it
[Laughter]
in all seriousness cones um
the doctor did not say that i couldn't
sing
you are my friend you
are the best and so
is andy you rock
you make us laugh you are so
sweet like cotton candy
i wrote this song today
that's why the lyrics are so shitty
but more much more than this
he
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he climbed the highest peak and then he
dove
into the ocean he curled
a million miles to give us
joy with the explosion
[Music]
much more than this
[Music]
to say the things he truly feels
and not the worse of one who kneels
the record shows he took the blows
he did it
[Music]
you're not supposed to do that
[Music]
you